merci merci françois noël si on veut
vraiment donner au français la
possibilité à nouveau de choisir qui
nous voulons accueillir sur notre
territoire
il est absolument nécessaire de refonder
la façon dont nous vérifions
l'intégration la capacité d'intégration
des personnes
or aujourd'hui les personnes arrivent et
seulement après on leur demande
d'exercer un certain nombre d'éléments
pour vérifier cette capacité ce que nous
souhaitons nous aujourd'hui c'est en
amont de la délivrance des titres de
séjours longs que nous ayons vérifier
que la personne a une connaissance une
acquisition de la langue française
suffisamment complexe et délié qui lui
permettra d'avoir une réelle intégration
avant de venir sur le territoire et non
pas après ce que nous souhaitons
également c'est que de vérifier que le
candidat ou la candidate à l'intégration
partage réellement les valeurs de la
république que cette personne partage
également réellement les valeurs qui
sont celles de l'ensemble des citoyens
français
l'égalité homme femme la laïcité et tous
ces éléments qui sont fondateurs de
notre vivre ensemble
encore une fois ce loi doit être
déterminé avant enfin parce que nous
sommes dans une situation économique qui
est complexe
pour beaucoup d'entre nous y compris
pour les immigrés en situation régulière
il est nécessaire que la personne puisse
faire preuve de sa capacité à exercer
une activité professionnelle ce qui va
lui permettre de garantir sa vie
économique sur notre territoire
et si toutefois cette personne ne
souhaite pas exercer d'activité
professionnelle
elle doit des nôtres démontré son
autonomie financière
voilà ce qui est pour nous de nature à
refonder une vraie intégration sur le
territoire est de nature à redonner à
chacun d'entre nous est bien la volonté
d'accueillir réellement un ensemble de
populations sur le territoire
si valérie